to present the next oscar is an actor
who knows what it's like to be nominated
knows what it's like to win and knows
what it's like to be one of the most
acclaimed actors in the world those are
nice things to know for those of us in
the under 5/8 Club he's a real giant
ladies and gentleman two-time Oscar
winner Dustin Hoffman
tonight's Best Picture nominees
awakenings Dances with Wolves Ghost
Godfather part 3 and Goodfellas are each
considered foreign films in France
Switzerland China Germany Italy and
everywhere else in the world so tonight
in our country the nominees for Best
Foreign Language Film are from France
Cyrano de Bergerac from Switzerland
journey of hope from the People's
Republic of China judo in Germany the
nasty girl from Italy open doors and the
Oscar goes to journey of hope on
accepting the award the film's director
Xavier :
oh I really I can't believe it myself I
would like to express my deep thanks to
all the members of the Academy and my
special thanks go first of all to the
family down in Turkey Anatolia who lost
their son in October 88
crossing the mountains into Switzerland
then I would like to thank all the
Turkish crew and actors m in Sivas
neural Nets made in Shabana who did a
great job on this film and also the
Italian crew members and the Swiss crew
and actors and my producers our vicinity
and a the further from corner and
Catholics thanks a lot those who join us
when Oscar returned